Sí pues los motivos principales de esta
decisión que toma el fiscal merrick
Garden es aislar es tratar de proteger
al departamento de justicia de todas las
críticas que ha venido recibiendo sobre
todo de parte del equipo de Donald Trump
que lo atacan al departamento de
justicia de estar politizado de que el
de que la administración de yo bailén
use al departamento de Justicia como
arma política además en una en una
intervención pública el fiscal médica
Garden Pues dijo que teniendo en cuenta
que tanto yo bailén como el ex
presidente Donald Trump habían anunciado
ya su interés de lanzarse a la
reelección a la presidencia en el 2024
pues entonces por esta razón principal
tenía que tomar esta medida extrema de
pues nombrar a un investigador especial
para investigar estos dos casos ya los
abogados de Donald Trump reaccionaron y
dijeron que obviamente era de esperarse
esta medida que iba a tomar
fiscal general teniendo en cuenta dice
los abogados de Donald Trump que el
departamento de Justicia está politizado
a favor de Joe biden y de la
Administración demócrata Cristóbal
hablemos ahora de quién es Jack Smith el
fiscal independiente no nombrado por
Garland
exactamente este señor Jack Smith
trabajó en la haya investigando era el
fiscal general El fiscal director de las
investigaciones de los crímenes en
kosovo de crímenes de guerra que se
cometieron en la antigua yugoslavia y
también trabajó como
director de integridad pública también
en el departamento de defensa de los
Estados Unidos en un comunicado Jack
Smith dijo que pues va a trabajar
arduamente para entregar los resultados
independientes de esta investigación no
sólo a esta investigación sobre la
posible los posibles vínculos de Donald
Trump con lo que pasó el 6 de enero del
2021 cuando se tomaron el Capitolio sino
también por haberse llevado desde la
Casa Blanca a su mansión en mara lago
documentos de alta sensibilidad Jack
Smith dijo que va a llegar hasta las
últimas consecuencias en esta
investigación independiente mente de
quién afecte